Speaker 1: But let me tell you something else.
The most important thing that needs to happen
and this is the final thing I want to talk
about on today's show, today's main show.
And that is that I think this January six
select committee, the Riot Committee, whatever
you want to call it.
They're now in over their heads.
I do not think this committee, as it is right
now, should be the lead investor investigatory
body into the Capitol riot.
I believe that it is time for Merrick Garland
to finally step up.
And appoint a special prosecutor to officially
start a criminal investigation into these
events.
Now, don't get me wrong, so far, for the most
part, I have been very happy with what the
select committee has done and the reason I
say they're in over their heads is because
of the sheer scope of what it is they're trying
to do, which, to be honest, we don't even
really know everything they're attempting
to do yet.
So, you know, we have to contend with that.
You know, they've got Trump out there, they
said, Oh, we may be looking at criminal activity
here, we may be looking at criminal activity
with these individuals.
We got Roger Stone, we got Steve Bannon now.
We got members of Congress.
And they can't even if they're from opposing
parties, heck, almost especially if they're
from opposing parties, they now really can't
do this in a nonpartizan way because you do
have lawmakers that do have to answer these
questions, they absolutely have to.
That's why a special prosecutor is now needed,
convene a grand jury and essentially take
it over for the most part.
Because the optics are always going to be
bad if you have a Democrat controlled committee
subpoenaing Republican members of Congress,
Republicans are going to weaponize that to
show that, oh, the whole thing is a Partizan
sham.
Look, they're going after our lawmakers because
this is so ridiculous.
Even though there's legitimate reason to go
after them, a special prosecutor could avoid
that.
To a degree, they're still going to claim
it's Partizan witch hunt.
But the bigger problem is the longevity of
this committee.
This committee is not going to be able to
wrap up this investigation by the midterms.
They're just not.
And if they do wrap up before then, then they've
cut corners in a lot of places and it's not
a complete investigation.
Special prosecutor avoids that problem.
Because what happens when Republicans win
back the House, if they win back the House,
they kill the committee, it's over.
They disband it.
And what happens if members of the committee
don't win reelection?
Well, then you're in for a real big problem
to a special prosecutor appointed by the attorney
general avoids all of those problems.
The Republicans wouldn't be able to squash
a special prosecutor, we've seen them try.
Trust me, we have.
But they weren't successful with it.
So that's what needs to happen now.
But 100 percent of that rests upon the shoulders
of Attorney General Merrick Garland, who is
apparently just made it clear he's not going
to do anything.
And for the record, part of the reason why
I say that there's no way this committee can
even wrap things up by the midterms or even
by next January, when the new Congress would
be sworn in.
Steve Bannon doesn't even go on trial for
contempt until July.
OK.
You're not going to have resolution for that.
Mark Meadows hasn't even been arrested yet,
so he'll be arrested or arraigned, and then
they'll set a trial, which will likely be
even further out from July.
So you're not going to get the cooperation
you need from these people.
Probably until after the election, because
if they lose the cases, they're going to appeal.
So this committee is doomed from the start
because of the way Congress itself is set
up.
But you avoid those problems.
A lot of them disappear completely.
If the thing is handed over to a special prosecutor
or multiple special prosecutors, you know,
appoint several.
There's really no limit to how many you could
appoint to handle each different aspect of
that.
The rally organizers could be one focus of
one prosecutor.
The Trump administration could be another.
The members of Congress could be another.
And then, of course, all the outside players
who weren't with the rally, they weren't with
the administration or Congress.
You know, you're Bannon's, you're Fox News
hosts who have been texting with Mark.
All of those other individuals could fall
or another one.
So there you go.
But anyway, listen, we're out of time for
today's show.
I'm Farron Cousins.
Find me on social media at fair and balanced.
We've got a wonderful bonus show coming up
for you today, including Roger Stone flip
flopping on what actually caused the Capitol
riot.
I'm Farron Cousins
Unidentified: in for David Pakman.
Thanks for tuning.